Dave Ruben Mr Florida man Mr Florida man
Mr Florida man that's right welcome to
the free state of Florida Tim how do you
feel it's wet it's wet and it's good you
look that's what she said you look moist
and dewy from our humidity and our
freedom it actually brings out the uh
the essence of people the the freedom is
palpable it's it's pretty sweet man I
mean I get it it's good in West Virginia
I get it but come on it does not get
better than this I disagree what could
possibly be better what could possibly
be better than this place oh man uh the
mountains we don't have mountains here
that is the one thing the one thing that
I do concede on the Florida thing we're
we're pretty flat sck I look out my
window I see mountains mountains aren't
bad we have uh we have we got freedom we
got water we got freedom we got bees
I'll give you I'll give you the beaches
and a little bit more freedom than we
have you know West Virginia is doing
pretty good though we're we're fighting
a good fight no you guys are doing all
right I got I got no problem with West
Virginia but I'm glad to see you here in
the Free State of Florida this is going
to be a blast it's going to be a good
week so thanks for coming